it's over for Ron Trump cheers new poll
showing Vivek ramaswamy overtaking
DeSantis for the number two spot in the
2024 GOP Primary still miles behind him
but many people are suggesting that the
Trump campaign is propping up these
polls propping up the vague ramaswamy
because Vivek is no real threat to Trump
and actually is nice to Trump supports
Trump in many ways and may actually be
you know just effectively on Trump's
sideways to send us his real competition
for him
this is I think this might be the second
or third poll showing that Vivek has
taken second place so if Trump's out of
the picture of Vivek may come in first I
don't know for sure in the prediction
markets we have uh Ron still in second
place but it looks like uh Vivek and Ron
are tied and the only reason Ronda
sandus is above him is because D comes
before R alphabetically as a people have
argued I don't know if that's true I
think we can jump down here and just see
that uh so right now they're saying that
it's actually 17 to 16. so DeSantis is
in second place but I'm curious what you
guys think about uh about this battle
and where Vivek ramaswamy ends up
because I think I've I watched this
really great clip I mentioned earlier
between him and Neil Cavuto man this
dude is as sharp as sharp can be he's
sharp as sharp as a box of knives this
is Grandma Swami he knows what to say
how to say it and uh I don't think a guy
like Vivek is purely genuine it would be
absurd to believe that this guy is a
saint who just believes the right things
and and has Whispers all the sweet
nothings into your ears he's a snake I
said it before I love snakes snakes are
dangerous you can hide in the grass and
if you don't see him there you're gonna
pay he's the kind of guy that will go in
there and change things for the better
unexpectedly I I trust him I I don't
know him that well but I I don't I'm
agreeing with what you're saying I don't
think he's saying everything all true
like George Washington he was a master
liar yeah that's my metaphors that's
like that's that's the Other Extreme
yeah he's the dude no step on snake bro
like do not mess with this this is what
I'm talking about he's that kind of guy
I think Vivek has over overwhelmingly
positive position that he's correct on
and there's a few things that he saw he
was pulling bad on and probably switched
to switch the narrative yeah that's
normal politics for anybody I think
overwhelmingly based on my conversations
with him he's legit genuine he really
does dislike the ESG stuff he's really
threat he really thinks it's a threat to
this country and he wants to win to push
back on it but here's what ends up
happening you're someone like Vivek
what's your specialty he did biotech he
did uh anti-esg financing those are his
areas of expertise when it comes to
issues of like government lockdowns in
war and foreign policy not as areas of
expertise so he gets into this and then
he's like I gotta figure out what's the
appropriate path to take when it comes
to foreign policy that's not my thing
and then he comes out with an opinion
that is
Incorrect and he gets heavily criticized
for it then six seven months later we
hear him again and he comes out with the
correct opinion that doesn't mean he's a
snake it means that he was like I don't
know enough about it I end up learning
about it and here's where I actually
stands I think when I say snake in the
sense that he's gonna go in there and
twist the pharmaceutical industry on its
head and no one has any idea it's coming
yeah like he he's not gonna even
intimate his intention
I think snake is kind of implying he's
uh evil duplicitous oh well I disagree I
love snakes I used to play with snakes
when I was little snake pooped on me
once a garter oh wow that's great I'm
like a bird poop just right out the skin
you know there's a difference between
snake poop and burp poop right bird poop
is lucky because they're flying around
snake poop is just kind of on you yeah
it was just on me I'm a big fan of
snakes snakes have no hate man they
really only will attack if they're out
there and frightened or attacked you
know they don't really if Trump trump is
the lion and they call you know the Maga
party the Maga symbol is the lion what's
Ron and what's Vivek Ron's the Rhino
Vivek the snake Rama
oh that's mean no those are both it's a
dangerously powerful creature of the
snake the Rhino and the fake the snake
yeah geez Trump supporter Maga 2024 Ian
over here no well I think I I've called
for Vic I said that I like into snake
probably like three months ago because
what I see in him is that he's not
playing his hand you don't know what
he's got and he's a not a billionaire
have a brilliant strategist the guy is a
is a hundred words hundreds of millions
of dollars
Donald Trump is going to come out in the
primaries and be like rhino run and
Vivek the snake
Donald Trump it's Donald Trump all the
way that's if you they want to hit
Donald it's Donald Trump if could you
imagine if Trump starts using Ian's
the snake Robert you know Jake the Snake
Roberts
Rhino Ron is better than Ron D it is
wow use the my powers for good and uh
Rama swampy I forgot who said that was
that Alex bruceowitz who said that I
don't think so no I remember the Trump
people tend to like here's here's what I
think the Trump supporters like
ramaswamy for one simple reason he
defends Trump on principle and correctly
well he defends principle yeah he
defends principle and and Donald Trump's
part of that principle it's not like it
could be anybody plug anybody into it
he'd still defend the process but when
and so I know all the defense people are
going to be like does Santa said that
these things were wrong too
When Donald Trump was being indicted
over what he got died over the Stormy
Daniels thing right is that that was the
first one the first one Ron said look I
don't know what goes into paying a porn
star hundreds of thousand dollars people
were like low blow like it it didn't
it's not the same like the Vex
approaches what they're doing to Trump
is wrong it is unjust and we must oppose
it Ron's position was more tepid even
the Fulton County indictment he just you
know gave a blanket I'll end the
weaponization of government statement he
always says I haven't read the
indictment which is odd to me um and
never mentions Trump by name so yeah I
think Trump supporters appreciate Rama
Swami going to the mat for him and and
being true to principals and I think if
DeSantis did that he would have a lot
more Goodwill with Trump supporters yeah
this is the funny thing I love that
Santa supporters are the most
entertaining people I tweeted uh what
happens if Donald Trump doesn't
surrender what happened you know will
the feds be sent to whatever state he's
in what if he flees to a red State and
they refuse to cooperate I get a
combination of Georgia the red states
that I'm like yes it's the one state he
has to go to to surrender so obviously
I'm not talking about him seeking refuge
in Georgia where he'll clearly be
arrested by Georgia police and then I I
followed up with Ronda Santos said that
that Trump should have fired these
Source prosecutors and Christopher Ray
and all that and previously stated that
he would not assist an act tradition so
I tweeted will Rhonda if he went to
Florida would Ronda Sanders stand by his
word and refuse to extradite Trump and
all of a sudden all of the tennis
supporters not every single one but a
bunch of them start insulting and
attacking me
claiming that my post was insulting to
Ron DeSantis and I'm just like yo this
is why the guy's losing
his base for whatever reason Ron
DeSantis has cultivated people who
assume any discussion of Rhonda Sanders
is an insult yeah they attack anybody
who brings up anything about him I can
only assume that the Trump campaign
hired shills to go on Twitter and attack
anyone while pretending while pretending
to be to Santa supporters so that nobody
wants to support the Santos dude so I
noticed a lot of the tdsers are the ones
who support sandus oh like a lot and the
tdsers like this there are people that
are extremely extremely mad about Trump
you know so I feel like it's kind of
like it became a thing because so many
of them were on his side you know they
just kind of have this visceral reaction
against Trump that's what they're wrote
into census they were there were there
were a lot of uh Republicans and
conservatives in 2016 who despised Trump
and did everything in the power to stop
him right then after a year or two they
were totally on board with Trump why
because of social pressure Trump won
yeah if they were not with Trump then
they were this weird they were Democrats
and so what ends up happening is these
neocons
they split into two factions we now
agree Trump is good please don't yell at
me and Trump was always bad we're gonna
go hang out with Democrats then you get
the Lincoln project I love the Lincoln
project so much because they were like
now that Trump has been defeated in 2020
they're like we're gonna start going
after other Republicans and it's just
like why
like Trump was the bad guy right why go
after literally any other Republican
don't you like Mitch McConnell he's your
guy huh no because it was grifting they
just wanted to find a group of people to
griffed off of and make money for or
make money from sorry yeah what I love
about Trump is like he's the great
revealer in many ways he's shown us who
these people truly are to their core
whether that's you know deep State
bureaucrats or your average never Trump
never Trumper on Twitter he has shown us
what these people are thinking so they
can no longer lie to us he's kind of
pulled the curtain back and I think
that's been an immense service to The
Republic yeah and that's why he has so
many a huge part of why I have so many
fans because he just he talks straight
and like you were talking about we're in
the apocalypse we're in this great
revealment time era where and he's just
like talking about the Deep State openly
and like for people that had been red
pilled they already kind of knew but to
hear it from the president while he's
president is like man people needed that
they just even the DC consultant class
like before Trump I had no idea how much
disdain peat like Coastal Elites or DC
Beltway Consulting have for average
Americans that just live regular
day-to-day lives I didn't know how much
they despised my values until Donald
Trump but hatred can I also just point
out with all due respect to Kyle
Kolinski he did not know what a farm
looked like well yeah he he was he took
he took a picture from a plane
calculusky is a very prominent uh
left-wing podcaster personality he's a
good dude he tries really hard and I
have tremendous respect for him because
he tries to be honest he just has
different opinions that's great him and
crystal ball they're fantastic
but the point is even among the people
that we can say we like and are good
people he posted a photo from a plane of
farms and said I wonder why it looks
that way and it's just like he got
roasted for it and insulted and it was
mean and I'm like yo this is an
educational opportunity for a coastal
Elite like Kyle to understand the world
that rural folk live in by simply saying
my friend good sir those are farms but
was was he asking his food comes he did
not understand what he was looking
wasn't he asking why do the Farms look
that way no no no no no no no no no he
said what are those things that was the
substance of his question he said I
don't know why the land looks like yeah
that's right that's right I think we
have the Tweet right here actually it's
this he said
let's just do this and find an actual
image
here we go he said this land by the uh
this is land by Colorado Kansas border
from a plane pretty cool I have no idea
how slash why it looks like this dude
it's called farming it's called property
line how do you not know that man and
that's that's that I'm sorry it is
absolutely wild I don't know how you
don't know yeah for someone to be
popular and to be ignorant is like
pretty disturbing but it happens it's
it's so beyond that it's it's it's like
you don't know how did you not know what
Farms I just my mind is blown by this
yeah me too well you can look at it like
a you know a neighborhood and see
properties like those are yards it looks
like a kid like Old MacDonald Had a Farm
like you know like it's so weird what
the heck Sean Davis said imagine being
mystified by the existence of farms I am
not bringing this up to like we we've
brought it up periodically it's from a
long time ago what what years I don't
know if we know what year it's from
years a couple years ago a couple years
ago and again like I like Kyle he's a
good dude he's he's a smart guy but my
point is not that he's a bad person it's
that no even when we're taught you you
talk about the the Beltway people who
despise rural Folk
think about people like Kyle who do who
does a show where he's very uh favorable
to Democrats in the left and he
literally doesn't know what a farm even
looks like these are the kind of people
and again not trying to drag Kyle but
these are the people that when I've been
on Twitter and was talking about
inflation I and and uh disruption of
supply line when I said what happens
when this Farm can't produce milk where
do you get your milk from they responded
with the store
I am not exaggerating and I said I get
that my point is where does the store
get their milk from and they responded
with what are you talking about it's
just there I am not exaggerating that is
a Verbatim quote from people on from a
guy on Twitter I got into an argument
with socialists with sickle and hammers
in their accounts and they say things
like it's just at the store dude what do
you mean oh they're trolling no no dude
you've still got you talking about no
you know you see you see the issue
I spent a decade Plus on the ground at
various protests where I physically
spoken with these people and have
experienced this over and over again and
you call it a troll yet Kyle klinsky did
not know what a farm looked like
yeah but a random internet commenter
although that's why I would say it's a
troll I would just assume it's a troll
first a high profile socialist account
with like 40 000 followers who post
about this all the time that says
something like that is no different from
Kyle kolinsky saying doesn't look like
40 000 followers that's a different
story I'm not talking like a guy with 10
followers okay there's like a pro
they're like prominent you know I got an
argument with the Socialist Party of
Great Britain that one was hilarious
when I was just like it was a similar
conversation what happens if somebody
wants to build a car as a hobby they're
like they can go and just get free car
parts from the factory and I'm like like
every communist system for free you can
just literally for no reason go
somewhere just take whatever you want if
the people knew you not technically
untrue because they use brute force to
do it like if someone knew you and they
wanted to agitate you they could message
you on Twitter and be like just say
really in names stuff until you can't
take it anymore and then you don't TV
yell about it I don't think Kyle's goal
with not knowing what a farm was was
intending to trick right-wingers into
thinking he was a I think he
genuinely didn't know it's like that
Meme ha jokes on them I'm just
pretending to be
like no dude there are a lot of people
that don't understand what supply chain
is and so in the supply line there are
people that don't understand where milk
comes from but dude coming from the
store like it just operates at the store
is the most bizarre concept it's not
it's bro it's called there's a concept
of object permanence but there's people
who let's try the this you ever see that
visualization test where it says
I chose a picture it shows five
silhouettes of a person and there's a
picture of an apple a drawing of an
apple
a flat single monotone drawing of an
apple an outline of an apple and then
nothing and it says which do you see in
your mind when you think of Apple
there are some people who say what do
you mean do you see you can see things
in your mind some people can't visualize
objects in their minds some people can
in their mind visualize a
three-dimensional Apple spin it around
slice it in half open it up and that's
the visualization abilities they use for
conceptualizing Bridges and buildings
and such some people can't do that some
people can't do basic math some people
can't make I can't think three moves
ahead not everybody has these abilities
but everybody can vote so when someone
says the milk is just at the store it's
because their logical
capabilities stops one degree from where
they are I go to the store and get milk
what do you mean milk comes from
somewhere else it's at the store where
we think and if this is where you can't
project your your cognitive faculties
onto other people yeah I can visualize
the whole supply chain
from from the birth of the cow I've gone
to the farms and I've I've talked to the
farmers and even I'm not an expert on
this but I certainly understand the milk
at the store came from somewhere from a
truck from a distribution facility from
bottling plant from a farm whatever and
there are people who can't comprehend
that now in the case of Kyle with all
due respect he just had never seen a
farm before my point is not that he's a
stupid person my point is that he is
pushing policy positions and encouraging
votes from a place of extreme ignorance
I am not going to pretend to be the
smartest person in the room or the world
I also do very similar things but I
think you know my point with this is
when it comes to passing Nationwide laws
I think it would be imperative for
people like Kyle to step back and say I
don't know a lot more often yeah and
being intelligent and being you can be
intelligent and be ignorant ignorant
just means you don't know the
information yet or you don't know the
information so Kyle's very intelligent
whether or not he's ignorant about
something you know a lot of people have
things they don't know that's one of the
great wonders of being a human you get
to learn and that's why I thought it was
stupid that everyone was insulting I'm
like dude Kyle's a nice guy he's like he
tries really hard he's fair to people
and uh back in the day one of the you
know one one of the reasons I give him a
lot of credit is that he he has
consistently defended Carl Benjamin from
all the lies and the smears of the media
when they were falsely characterizing
him as racist he would reject and be
like dude we don't know don't do that
that's not fair address the arguments
and I'm like this is a good dude but he
doesn't know what a farm looks like that
means when he goes on his channel and
says hey guys you should Vote for This
policy in that policy you you know that
he's missing a huge portion of knowledge
in certain areas I'm not saying he's
talking about voting policy on farms or
anything I'm just saying yo when people
talk about stuff on Twitter
most people don't know anything yeah
yeah and I mean even in government like
how many people in the U.S department of
Agriculture building in DC right now
have no experience firsthand on a farm
probably a large number yeah thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time